among the screens most memorable couples
Romeo and Juliet rhett and Scarlett I
can Tina black and blue well they may
not have been our favorite memories of
that particular couple but I don't think
anybody will ever forget the
oscar-nominated performances of the two
actors who played the Turner's together
again and a lot more peacefully this
time the beautiful Angela Bassett and
the stunning Laurence Fishburne
do you know something Lawrence
nobody's ever answered the question that
we asked question was that Angela hmm
what's love got to do with it yeah well
love that's a subject you're better off
just singing about you want to sing oh
me no no not me but I'll tell you who
will to recap this year's nominees for
best song take six
music by Alan Menken and the lyric by
Steve
the song did man walking music and lyric
my crew you seen Springsteen
from Don Juan DeMarco have you ever
really loved the warmer Milligan lyric
haha
Michael came in Bryan Adams and Robert
Chang from
music
front I story you've got a friend Andy
if I break these are the nominated songs
yeah
and the Oscar goes to Alan Menken and
Stephen Schwartz for the colors of the
wind
from Pocahontas
well uh Thank You Vanessa Williams and
thank you Judy Kuhn for your wonderful
performances of the song and Robbie
Buchanan for wonderful production of the
single arrangement of the single and
Keith Thomas for your production Steven
we want to express our appreciation to
the members of the Academy our deep
gratitude to our colleagues at Disney
past and present and I want to
acknowledge my personal debt to the
Native American poets and wisdom keepers
who inspired my work on this project was
particularly in the case of this song
chief Seattle thank you very much